[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm any update on the Jimmy situation
handled my leash he is in good spirits
and should be returning to practice
today
yeah so he no longer wants to be traded
well that must be him now do something
don't worry you can't do [ __ ] against me
I hope that means you worked on your
defense
I'll take those to tear out cousins the
muffin make us boy and that their mangy
goat when a mob whatever's left of you
chilly living cowards off the court
oh that's just Jimmy gotta love the
intensity brings even to practice
actually no dressing are using as we
said how schools if you're not mortally
wounded you can still play for 10
minutes too big part of me
you've seen my heart not now Thomas it
might be time to meet this situation is
untenable what's terrible it's very
terrible it's one of the most tenable
situations I've ever attended we work
out just fine if we're just patient your
rotation
well I do suppose I like Robert
competence hustle how exciting is this
Lord Commander Jimmy can take us over
the top he could change everything with
its intensity aw here it comes now
they're mini carriage sure does have a
lot of baggage I'd like to be traded
please shall we complete this process
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good people of YouTube please pledge
your fealty to the kingdom of followers
and click subscribe it shows support for
the show and allows us to send you
Ravens when new episodes come out